المتجدده لن تجلب فقط الطاقه النظيفه
لكنها سوف تزيد من امن الطاقه في اوكرانيا
لانها
ذات منشا داخلي ولان الطاقه تكون اكثر
امنا نحن نعمل الان من اجل اتاحه التمويل
كبير
لللوائح اللوائح الواح الطاقه الشمسيه
التي سيتم نشرها في اوكرانيا سندعو الدول
الاعضاء والشركاء للانضمام الى هذه
المبادره
هدفنا هو توفير الطاقه الكهربائيه للمباني
الحكوميه بضمان طاقه كهربائيه مستقره
للمستشفيات والمدارس من خلال هذه الالواح
الشمسيه التي يتم تركيبها على اسطح
المباني
وسنوقع اليوم مذكر التفاهم بشان الغاز
المتجدد مثل الميثان والهيدروجين
هذه خطوات ملموسه جدا باتجاه اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا الخضراء
واعاده الاعمار في الواقع هي الموضوع
الواسع نحن في هذه المعركه معا وسوف نعيد
اعمار هذا البلد الجميل معا
ويسمحوا لي هنا ان اركز على اعاده الاعمار
نحن نعمل الان معا من اجل اتاحه
مليار يورو لبدء اعاده الاعمار السريع
يمكن ان نبدا العمل فورا
مع
توفر هذا المبلغ الذي سوف تضاف اليه اموال
اخرى الموضوع الكبير الواسع كما قلت هو
اعاده الاعمار وهنا نحسد دعم العالم
منصه التنسيق لمجموعه السبع قائمه الان
وهذه المنصه تساعد على تنسيق المساعده
الدوليه وستدعمكم ايدي تنفيذ اجنداتكم
ثم هناك شعار لدى الامانه التي تقودها
بلادكم والمفوضيه والامانه موجوده هنا في
كيف وبروكسيل على حد سواء
بلدان مجموعه السبع وغيرها وكذلك مؤسسات
الى الدوليه هي مستعده الان لارسال اشخاص
لدعميه او الجهود عبر الامانه حتى نجمع
الجهود من اجل اعاده الاعمال الاقتصاديه
وانجاح هذه العمليه